(chill guitar music)
- [Wes] On a research boat,
usually it's the new guy
who gets the dirtiest job.
- [Man] You guys got spit on.
- This time is no exception.
I'm Wes Larson, a wildlife biologist
and lover of the outdoors for
as long as I can remember.
I'm traveling the country to find
the next generation of conservationists.
The people on the front lines
of the fight to understand our planet,
and protect the animals we share it with.
We got a pretty big hermit crab.
(laughing)
Today, I'm headed to Sarasota,
on the Gulf Coast of Florida.
It's home to a beautiful but
little understood animal,
the spotted eagle ray.
I'm joining up with a research team
from Florida Atlantic
University and Mote Marine Lab.
They're some of the first
scientists in the world
to study this animal in depth.
So, Breanna, what are we doing today?
- So, today we're gonna attempt to
visually spot some spotted eagle rays.
Bring it onboard, take a bunch of samples,
and then we'll release
it back into the wild.
- I am way excited.
Breanna DeGroot is a
master student at FAU.
She's been obsessed with rays
ever since she was 11 years old.
And, she's leading the
field research today.
Spotted eagle rays are
pretty understudied,
we really don't know a
lot about them, right?
- Yeah, there's not a
whole lot of information
about just even their
basic biology or ecology.
So, what do they mean for the environment,
how are they affecting the environment,
how many of 'em are out there?
And, from an environmental component,
they're really important to keeping
the ecosystem in balance.
So, it's really important
that we understand
basic questions about them,
which is what we're trying to do here.
- So, we're up on the spotting tower.
It's quite the view up here.
You can definitely see into the water
a lot better than you can down there.
- They stand out pretty good.
We're gonna go over a grass bed right now.
They have a tendency to hide in the grass.
- [Wes] What we're looking
for is a ray large enough
to surgically implant a tracker.
And, it takes an
experienced eye to spot one.
- Right there.
- [Woman] Is it an eagle ray?
- Yeah, I believe so.
That's him, that's him.
That's an eagle ray, dude.
- [Man] Be ready.
(yelling)
- Catching a ray is a
complicated maneuver.
We have to completely
encircle it with the net,
or the ray will escape, and
you've gotta be quick about it.
The water's really choppy,
and these maneuvers
that they do with the boat
are really aggressive.
- [Woman] He's in the net.
- [Man] You got him?
Yeah, he's in there.
- We got him.
- Yeah.
- [Wes] Once we've got it surrounded,
we need to bring in the ray by hand.
- He's in the middle;
he's going to the north.
Oh, geez.
- Beauty.
- This ray turns out to
be tiny, just a juvenile.
My job is to hold it in place
while the team does their work.
And, despite its size, it's not easy.
Yeah, I can see how a big
one would be pretty strong.
- So, flip him.
- Flip him?
OK.
As soon as we flipped him over,
you can really see how
much he's calmed down.
That's a state that they go
into called tonic mobility,
it's kinda like the ray's hypnotized.
A lot easier to work with
than when he was on his belly.
They get, they're quite a
bit bigger than this, right?
- [Breanna] Yes, they get
to be about seven feet.
- I wanna catch a seven foot ray today.
- We'll look for a seven foot ray.
- [Wes] This ray is too small
to surgically implant a tracking device.
So, once we've gathered what data we can,
it's time to let him go.
He's off into the wild.
And, while the spotters keep an eye out
for a big ray, we take
a break from the hunt.
When you begin researching an animal,
one of the most fundamental
things to understand
is its eating habits.
And, to figure out the eagle ray's,
the team has come up
with a creative solution.
- [Woman] We're going in, everybody in.
Scour the area.
- So, Breanna, this is kinda
what we're looking for, right?
- [Breanna] That's exactly
what we're looking for.
- [Wes] And, this is a gastropod?
- Yes, so.
- Or, for the layman.
- Fancy name for a snail.
- A snail.
K.
- Yeah, a marine snail.
- [Wes] We take back the
snails and clams to the lab,
where the team has two wild
rays in a holding tank.
- We're gonna put some
prey items into the water,
and we're going to record the sounds
that they're making while
they're crunching down
on the hard shelled prey items.
And, we're trying to decipher if
these different prey items are making
different signature sounds.
- [Wes] By tracking the sounds
that different shells make
when the rays crunch
them, the team believes
that they can decipher
the eagle ray's diet.
(crunching)
- And, that's the big.
- He just crunched it there.
- [Breanna] Exactly, yup.
Well, the hope is to put
these listening stations
out into the environment, and we can know
exactly what they're eating,
when they're eating it.
And, how much they're consuming.
- [Wes] As the captive rays crunch away,
we get word that another
has been spotted offshore.
- That's bigger.
- [Wes] So, it's time to
head back into the gulf,
for one last attempt to catch a big one.
- We just got word that there's another
spotted eagle ray about double the size
of the ones that we've
currently been catching.
So, we're on our way to go relocate it,
and hopefully, we'll
get another ray onboard.
- [Man] Get ready.
- Ready?
- [Wes] It's pretty clear when
the team grabs the other net
that this is a much bigger ray.
- [Woman] To your left, to your left.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Man] Yeah, high.
- You guys ready?
- [Man] Nice and easy.
You got enough water yet?
Lift him all the way up.
- All the way up.
All the way up.
- Lower down.
- Down, down, down.
Perfect.
- [Man] Little bigger
than the last one, huh?
- Yeah. (laughing)
- Yeah, just a little bit.
It's unreal how strong their wings are.
This ray is over 5 feet wide
from wingtip to wingtip.
Plenty big enough for the
surgery Breanna is hoping to do.
Turn around like that?
- Yeah.
- [Wes] And, my job,
holding the ray upside down
and perfectly still while she
implants the tracking tag.
- So, what you want is
to like, yeah, like lay.
Figure out the best position for you
to raise this part with your body.
- OK.
- So, preparing all of
our surgery supplies
to do an internal acoustic surgery.
It's a really quick procedure,
where an internal tag is
implanted into their belly area.
And, it allows up to
follow their movements
as they travel up and down the coastline.
- Is she gonna react to this?
- She shouldn't.
Ready?
- [Woman] Yeah.
- [Breanna] If you start
to feel her clench.
- K.
- Just let me know.
- I will.
Sharks and rays don't feel
pain the same way humans do.
And, with the ray on its back,
it stays calm and relaxed
throughout the procedure.
Yeah, that was quick.
You guys did a good job.
The surgery is over in just a few minutes.
This tag will allow the team to track her
for years to come, giving
them a detailed picture
of where eagle rays live,
and how far they travel.
Putting us one step closer
to understanding this beautiful animal.
I come from a mammal background.
And, working with mammals,
there's kind of this
natural connection that
you have with them.
And, I didn't really expect to have
that sort of connection with these rays.
But, when we pulled 'em up onto the boat
I felt this intelligence
coming out of them.
They're a very personable animal.
- Yeah, that's the
reaction most people have.
They're highly intelligent,
and obviously, their beauty
and grace just helps us form
another connection to them.
- [Wes] I've heard people
say there isn't much mystery
left in nature, but eagle rays remind me
that there are still animals
we know hardly anything about.
Answering the basic questions can help us
better understand them and, in turn,
protect whole ecosystems.
Watching this discovery
firsthand was a true privilege.
It makes me wonder what
other hidden secrets
must be waiting out there.